et c'est avec Anthony Saint-Léger
bonsoir Anthony bonsoir Audrey bonsoir à
tous des internautes alimentent les
mystères quant à l'origine des fuites
des North stream 1 et 2 en partageant
des vidéos effectivement on a découvert
l'une d'entre elles ensemble 16 secondes
très exactement regardez ce sont ses
avions qui patrouille dans le ciel 5
avions vraisemblablement militaire alors
que nous disent les internautes qui les
partagent et bien que c'est avions
survolent le territoire allemand et vous
allez voir que ça à son importance c'est
le cas de ces deux internautes par
exemple Allemagne de l'Est même nous
précise celui-ci et pourquoi ça a son
importance parce que si dans le contexte
actuel on regarde évidemment le Nord
Stream il lit la Russie à l’allemagne au
niveau de l'Est justement dans la mer
Baltique alors l'autre internaute qui
nous intéresse aussi c'est cette mention
du nordrope B2 Spirit c'est cet avion en
fait que l'on voit là un avion militaire
américain à la forme assez
reconnaissable que l'on voit ici qui a
crédit donc la thèse que les États-Unis
ont quelque chose à avoir là-dedans et
qu'en est-il réellement un faux ou intox
et bien c'est une intox et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce cas n'est pas
très viral mais il est assez atypique
d'une décontextualisation d'une vidéo
pour essayer de faire coller à
l'actualité et de faire dire un peu ce
qu'on veut aux images je vous parle
souvent de la recherche d'image inversée
dans le cas précis elle n'a absolument
rien donné en fait la réponse elle n'est
nous est venue d'un des commentaires à
la vidéo via ce lien Tik Tok lorsqu'on
le clique dessus tout bêtement on
retrouve la vidéo en question de sur ce
constructeur sur ce compte Tik Tok un
compte qui est en fait spécialisé dans
la publication différente images et
bâtiments militaires notamment américain
on n'a pas beaucoup plus d'infos sur le
contexte de la vidéo mais ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est que alors il
s'agit bien du
du nordrope en question que l'on
retrouve ici donc et ça ce sont bien
quatre avions de chasse en l'occurrence
df22 Raptor donc des avions de chasse
américain ce qui nous intéresse surtout
c'est regarder la date 17 novembre
2021 donc une certitude c'est que cette
vidéo est au moins du 17 novembre 2021
et qu'elle n'a donc absolument rien à
voir avec cette histoire de North stream
sabotage le mot est sur toutes les
lèvres des Occidentaux et des Russes qui
se renvoient les accusations
effectivement difficiles de percer le
mystère à Moscou et le premier suspect
des
occidentaux le Kremlin qui demande vous
le savez demain vendredi une réunion du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU et qui
accuse les États-Unis en croire par
exemple ce télégram ce poste de Maria
zacharova la porte-parole de la
diplomatie russe qui vous le voyez a
publié une vidéo de Joe Biden et qui
nous dit ceci dans cette publication
télégram le président Joe Biden est
obligé de répondre à la question de
savoir si les États-Unis d'Amérique ont
réalisé leur menace alors de quelle
menace par le t-elle et bien la réponse
en images regardez
une déclaration ancienne qui a été
exploité pour semer le doute
effectivement ces mots nous y mettrons
fin et date du 7 février 2022 c'est donc
une menace mise à exécution selon le
Kremlin on l'a vu mais également selon
certains Américains de cœur Carlson le
présentateur phare de Fox News qui nous
dit dans un tweet et dans une
intervention télévisée que si Vladimir
Poutine n'a pas trop d'intérêt à sa
beauté les certains états longs ils
l'ont fait savoir en public nous dit-il
évidemment une référence à jobiden et
aux États-Unis de même une référence
faite par Donald Trump il y avait
longtemps via ce réseau le Truffaut
social Chouf maintenant donc qui publie
cette déclaration et notamment cette
vidéo annonciatrice donc d'une troisième
guerre mondiale
et cette vidéo cette séquence elle est
reprise par de nombreux complotistes sur
les réseaux sociaux mais rappelons le
contexte en fait cette déclaration a eu
lieu je vous le disais le 7 février on
est 17 jours avant le début de la guerre
en Ukraine Nord Stream 2 les États-Unis
ils sont opposés on le sait et deux
semaines avant la publication de enfin
la déclaration pardon de Joe Biden
Victoria nellen c'était déjà exprimé à
ce propos si il y avait invasion de la
de l'Ukraine par la Russie et bien le
Nord Stream 2 n'irait pas de l'avance
sous entendu il y aurait des pressions
diplomatiques et non pas une idée de
frapper en tout cas de viser ce North
stream là et pour cause Nord Stream 2
était certes construit mais il n'était
pas opérationnel à l'époque il n'avait
pas reçu ni la validation de l'Allemagne
ni celle de l'Union européenne je vous
le disais les États-Unis sont opposés au
Nord Stream 2 la guerre en Ukraine a
bouleverse a bouleversé les choses si
bien que quelques semaines après cette
et bien l'Allemagne par la voie du
chancelier allemand Olaf Scholtz a tout
simplement mis fin à la procédure
d'homologation de ce fameux Nord Stream
2 merci beaucoup pour